sales tactic that has directly made over
35 million dollars one day i sold a
bunch of people into a new program that
was starting that was probably like 15
orientations deep and i just headed no
after no and finally i was sitting down
and this nice lady walked in and she had
like a nice ring and a nice purse she
sits down i remember getting to the end
of the presentation and i just said hey
so with the program you want chocolate
or vanilla for your protein and she was
like which one do you like i was like
chocolate she was like all right i'll
take one of those for the pre-workout do
you want to do kiwi or strawberry i i
like the kiwi she was like okay i'll do
that one so i said do you want to just
use the card you have on file and she
was like yeah that's fine and then i
took these off the shelf and i slid them
over to her she grabbed them and she
smiled and she walked out of the
facility and i made my first supplement
sale and i was like holy i didn't even
talk at all about what these even did i
just simply asked her which one she
wanted and the key was i didn't ask her
whether she wanted them i asked her
which one she wanted that is when i was
introduced to the assumed close it is
one of the strongest upsells in all of
business